so that a whimsical feeling that you
have like childlike yeah that's
something that I [ __ ] then I lost ya
along the way and go right when you just
said that dude I was just like I want
that back I know you know I mean because
now I go to the comedy store I just pee
on the wall yeah I smoke inside I action
side I couldn't agree with you more
I don't even show up ask him I got my
own spin-off off the Goldbergs and I
love the Goldbergs alone but what I do
is as excited as beautiful as amazing it
as it is in my brain I'm like well to
pilot but you know chances are you know
I'm not gonna I'm not even I don't get
excited I don't know what's gonna happen
my guess is it's not gonna go anywhere
cuz I've been through that so many times
I visited me when I was on animal
practice
Brow's on it right yes and I remember I
was shooting something next I know you
were well I remember thinking Brian
Inara killing it right now right and
then like eight weeks later I'm crying
in my car because it got canceled I know
and it devastated me of course you know
I think it's good to care about stuff
like that like it's in off see you guys
that's how you deal with it but whenever
you know I'm waiting to hear on to show
some goes don't think about it's not in
port man if it happens happens I'm like
well no I really want to get it yeah
yeah I do think about it and real quick
if I don't get it
I'm be really upset what's wrong I
really want song with that yeah yeah
imagine getting it then all of a sudden
you know how much money you're making a
week yeah and then all of a sudden out
of the blue they take it away I was
terrible banana malpractice what I had
inside information I knew that thing was
gonna go away I couldn't tell you
dude dude what's up no booboo be real I
couldn't tell you no you you [ __ ]
swear to God I swear to God for sure
though be pretty [ __ ] you call
yourself a friend bro but you didn't
know for sure that's just a bad guy
thing no it's no it's not a bad guy cuz
what it was was in my mind I was like I
was hoping that I was wrong right but
you know how people talk right and for
me I was like I was like I knew how
badly one is and I thought to myself no
no listen I thought that myself
go I go I I [ __ ] hope that executive
is wrong
I remember good thinking to myself cuz I
got I wanted to go so badly for you cuz
you and I are in the same boat
you finally got in this show I knew how
badly you wanted it but the guy says now
that having problems and I and I I would
never tell you that why would I ever
tell you I'll tell you why why I'll tell
you why your hope I'll tell you why it
might have gone you know that you you
don't know cuz all of a sudden the shows
a hit and I said something pretty now
I'm and now I'm the [ __ ] man like a
hater yeah you can't do that yeah here's
something right now okay you and I feel
like we were friends ya know really
we're friends I've been to your house so
we care about it you care about each
other right and what you just did there
right was [ __ ] sabotage in the [ __ ]
deepest way oh my god if you get rid of
bobbili fix it with me fix it with me
and the show will go because then now
what I think is is that if you saw my
girlfriend holding hands with another
guy walking on the beach that you
wouldn't tell me oh no I tell you that's
bad you would tell me unless he was the
guy who listen when I get in there and
you're there and I'm on set and I hear
that the show is having problems as far
as ratings you're right and how do you
say it how the [ __ ] right I'm gonna
piss on your parade happy stay your life
you're on set loving it right I'm gonna
come in and go ahead by the way that's
something Rogan did Rogan did Bethenny
well I was doing inside Schwartz I think
at the time and I was just shot at them
yeah well why because it was nested
between Will and Grace and [ __ ]
friends oh my god hi yeah yeah huh it
was the it was right there was like
that's it I made it and Rogan goes
inside the information he goes that
shows going away you got to know that
right I go huh what about what I got up
shopping less I'm redecorating great I'm
a sitcom I'm I'm famous yeah give the
guy the Will and Grace had gotten
Porsches the year before they had been
their bonus was Porsches everybody got a
fortress we're like and I remember
talking to the director who is the
director of Lola grace we're like you
think we'll get portions
you're pretty good I admire shooting
baskets yeah like you think maybe we'll
get Porsches and guess what went away
yeah but Rogan Rogen broken just the
fifth rogue in the true that's how it's
not true top hey let's go away yeah you
know [ __ ] right you know shit's going
away so yeah you gotta know yeah let's
do that
yeah very very glad it's on your parade
I would never do that to ya because I
don't know when you see my back ripple
and I pull myself up like a champ like a
champ through 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift